[Music]
search engine optimization is a powerful
way to increase the visibility of your
business at its most basic search engine
optimization is about increasing the
rankings of your website at its most
complex it is managing the programming
content visibility and success of a
website and much more search engines are
the primary way that people find
information if you are not visible in
the search engines then your customers
won't find you search engine
optimization enables you to know what
your customers want and enables you to
be found search engine optimization has
changed over the years and some early
methods are not only ineffective but
could get you into trouble with the
search engines because of this it is
important to keep up-to-date on the
latest information and continually
increase your knowledge and skills
search engine optimization is the number
one activity for successful businesses
as it all starts with search developing
skills in this area will enable you to
provide an invaluable service to
companies and also provide a base for
additional skills related to search
engine optimization
in this practitioner course the content
will be broken down in these areas
looking at how search engines work
understanding how human factors are
related to how important we're going to
look deeply at the foundation of
keywords and how to use those keywords
in both on-page and off-page
optimization obviously you're going to
have to learn some technical programming
and some technical tricks to help you
manage your website more effectively and
make it more friendly for search engines
and then we're going to look
specifically at marketing your business
marketing your business online
especially if you have a local business
there are many opportunities available
to you but also some planning as far as
building a new website redesigning your
current website and additional changes a
walk you through the steps for a
marketing plan and then ultimately how
to measure everything what's working why
it's working and how to react to that
let's look at our first section we're
going to spend some time understanding
how search engines work do you ever
wonder why the search engines present
the results the way they do everything
from the colors the words the
arrangement of the content has gone
through scrutiny in order to present the
most pleasing relevant results that is
designed to get you to enjoy the user
experience and so we're going to look at
how the search results are produced the
factors that influence the rankings
within search engines and the algorithm
the algorithm is the mathematical
formula that determines which pages are
ranked higher than others we're also
going to look at how a search engine
sees your website and how those search
results are designed to get you to click
or stay on the search results
what's vitally important is
understanding the human connection to
search engines you see the search
engine's primary customer is the human
the searcher and so the search results
are made specifically to connect to your
brain and there are factors that make us
pay attention and click and help decide
on which results are more relevant than
others and ultimately it comes down to
the importance of words now because
words are so important we are going to
spend a lot of time on understanding
keywords keywords are the words that
people type into the search engine and
so that is the foundation of all online
marketing you will do the skills you
develop through this course of
understanding researching organizing and
developing keywords in your marketing
content are going to spill over in other
areas that will help you be a better
marketer and will help you build your
online business more effectively you can
use these same skills in paid search in
social marketing buying ads writing
content and developing multimedia the
reason why words are so important is
that shows us the intent of our searcher
when we understand the intent of the
searcher that helps us better understand
what they need and so we can write our
content and adjust it to fit what the
searcher needs we're going to cover how
to use keyword tools to build and gather
keyword lists and then how you can
evaluate them for more effectiveness
going to take those keywords and through
the on-page optimization section you'll
understand better how to implement those
keywords into your content into your
website and we'll look at the key areas
the key elements of the page that are
most important and then also your
content structure how you present your
content sometimes just as important as
what's on the page we'll look at the
navigation and the type of content
that's important to optimize based on
being an e-commerce site a publisher a
blogger whatever type of content you
might have and then how to avoid
penalties in the search engines in the
off page optimization section we're
primarily going to look at link building
you see search engine algorithms take in
two very important account how many
links come to your site but not only how
many how quality those links are meaning
links from sites are not equal
some sites have a higher influence than
other sites and so we're going to look
at the types of links that you can get
we're going to evaluate those links how
to optimize them and how to build links
through many different media and
opportunities and then how to use
software there are linked tools out
there that will help you maintain and
manage the links coming to your site as
well as give you ideas for additional
link building there are also some
programming know-how you've got to
employ in order to make your site
friendlier for search engines everything
from the URL structure how you link
pages and maybe how you redirect pages
from a previous version of your website
these are all the little details that
add up and you just have to know how to
do these things we're going to provide
an overview of most of the problems
you'll encounter but also point you in
the direction of some of the tools that
are available through the search engines
themselves to help make this a little
bit easier
now if you are a local business as I
said there is a lot available to you
through the search engines to enhance
your listings in the search engines of
results you can get additional business
listings you will have maps click to
call functionality and additional
measurements that you can use to show
the effectiveness of your online
marketing and of course not every
website stays the same there is always
things that you need to do in order to
grow your site whether it's building a
new website and choosing a new domain
name or redesigning your current site
also what to do if there might be a
problem we'll have a troubleshooting
section as well to help you figure out
what might be going wrong most
importantly we're going to look at
building a marketing plan for your
business going beyond the rankings and
looking at what all we can do to improve
the effectiveness of our businesses
online I'll show you how to do some
competitive assessments but also how to
manage a team and or if your individual
how your job affects other people in the
marketing department or in the business
of the website ultimately then we're
also going to look at how to protect
yourself from further updates from
search engines and their algorithm
updates of course you want to protect
yourself and not get on the wrong side
of a search engine
otherwise you may find your website has
been taken out of the results
with analytics we'll look to see what
you can measure to show true success of
all your efforts you're putting in a lot
of work with optimization and doing a
lot of these changes so obviously you'll
want to be able to show some results of
your work analytics will provide the
numbers you need as well as factors that
will help you understand what you can do
to continue your improvement not just to
improve rankings but to improve your
overall business online well first of
all why it is search so important from a
business perspective there is an initial
investment in terms of optimizing the
website and then a maintenance level of
looking at what's working improving
things that can be improved and also
watching out for anything that might go
wrong that might need to be fixed so
there is an initial investment there's
some ongoing investment but the nice
thing is is once things are in place it
lasts for years many websites that have
gotten into the top page of result tend
to keep that result and keep that
placement for many years afterwards
because of that search engine
optimization can over time produce a
very predictable return on investment
it's very predictable how many visitors
you can get in a certain month when you
start comparing the data from previous
years based on activity based on your
visibility if you're a local business
there are many local features available
to you to enhance your visibility and
provide additional services so that you
can reach the people in your local area
search engine optimization is one of the
most cost effective things that you can
do to promote your website and promote
your business and also the skills
necessary for search engine optimization
they're integrated they are also used
across multiple digital marketing
disciplines let's first look at the
importance of search even when people
are looking for information on a branded
product the vast majority will go to a
search engine first rather than going to
the
brands website rather than going to a
retailer overwhelmingly people go to
search first they want to see all of the
information that's available about that
brand good and bad they want to see what
other websites what reviews what other
people are saying so that they can have
a wider group of informational sources
from which to make a decision now the
importance of that visibility of being
on that first page is dramatic if you're
on that first page and there are ten
results on that first page that will
receive about 94% of the attention now
this is not for every single case this
is just in general and so as we looked
at before that there are different
results for different types of searches
this number is going to vary but just as
a guide you can see that being in the
first page or being in the first ten
results that is going to give you more
visibility substantially more visibility
you see the next 10 results 11 through
20 only receive about 6% of impressions
now again this is not the rule this is
only a guide and you will see
differences based on the type of
industry the type of website the type of
information that you have it doesn't
take a genius to figure out that having
top rankings equals more visitors again
this is not always the case this is not
always 100% it's a general trend but
most visitors will click the number one
result the number two result gets about
half of that the number three result
it's about two-thirds of that and it
goes on however 71% of the searches
result in a click on a page one result
on the first page the first five results
account for over half of all the clicks
67% page two and three only get less
than six percent of the clicks so again
not only is visibility
important being on the first page but
also the hiring rankings you are the
more chance you have of getting clicked
but it doesn't always have to be number
one it's being in general being in the
top rankings you can't control it in
fact you're going to see variations from
many different aspects that's why we
don't always measure rankings but we
look at the consistency of visibility
search engine optimization provides
great return on investment in a recent
survey businesses were asked which
activity provided the best return now
when it came to excellent email
marketing receive 22% of people saying
it was excellent
search engine optimization received 20%
in rating it as good search engines
receive 47% email 46% and even content
marketing has more to do with organic
search and so people see Pacific return
on their investment the money that they
put in to optimizing their content
optimizing their websites they see a
solid return more so than most other
channels that they use to market their
business in another survey when people
and companies were asked to rate their
customers based on how they acquired
those customers they compared how they
received those customers to the average
customer lifetime value and what they
found is that customers that were
acquired through organic search had a
50% higher than average lifetime value
really what that meant is that customers
acquired through organic search spent
more than the average customer and they
had a longer lifetime than the average
customer which made these companies
realize that customers acquired through
search were high-value customers more so
than their average customer when we
compare this to on the other side the
raph what we see is Twitter the people
that came from Twitter had less than 20%
than average lifetime value and really
it doesn't take much to look at the
difference between organic search and
Twitter the reason why organic search
provided such high value customers is
because when people have a need they
search they go to a search engine it is
an active activity it is a dynamic
process of moving forward to solve a
problem whereas going on Twitter and
looking at things as a more passive
process and typically people will find
something that interests them click on
it and respond but yet the investment is
not there
they weren't actively proactively going
and looking for a solution they found
something that interested them and so as
a result it was a more passive activity
they weren't as emotionally invested in
solving the problem and so they didn't
become a high-value customer typically
when compared to other channels now one
of the concepts in search engine
optimization has been developed by
Google over the past few years they call
this micro moments this is really based
on the proliferation of smartphones and
the availability and the always-on
mentality you see before smartphones if
we had a question we had to maybe go to
a desktop computer or go somewhere where
we could go online now that we have
computers in our pockets we can look at
them anytime and our behavior has
changed dramatically because of that
ability this is what's called micro
moments you see when people used to go
online and they would research it would
be over a period of maybe 20 minutes to
an hour or more they would research they
would look for activities they would do
what they needed to do to make a
decision now however our time seems to
be spread out and we look for things
when we have the inspiration rather than
making time to sit down and research
we research when an idea hits us and
that's the micro moment the average
micro moment is about a minute long of
people just looking for information
turning off their phone and putting it
back and then maybe later
they have another idea and they will
search on that and so our behavior has
changed dramatically and it's also
changed our information demands google
has really distilled down typical
searcher behavior into four types of
micro moment queries I want to do I want
to buy I want to go and I want to know
these are the typical questions that
people are asking when they go online
for these micro moments as an example
Google published this research of
someone who was looking for a car they
had over 900 digital touch points over
three months during their decision to
buy a car 71% of those 900 digital touch
points were done on a mobile device now
of those 900 touch points there was 139
Google searches 14 YouTube videos were
watched 89 images were viewed they had
69 dealer interactions and 186
manufacturer interactions over the
course of 3 months they started looking
at 14 different brands they eventually
came down to the consideration phase
amongst experience and ultimately
decided between two brands this is the
new micro moment behavior that all of
these interactions took place over three
months and over 900 digital touch points
that would be a micro moment of having
an inspiration a question going online
asking and then responding when the
information is received search engine
optimization is a growing field forced
to research has found that the average
company over the coming years expects to
allocate about 30 to 35 percent of their
marketing budget to digital to online
marketing and search engine marketing
search engine
zatia is expected to take the largest
share of that spend at almost 50% about
14% of the total budget now this means
that as companies realize that search
engine optimization is not just
something that they should do but it's
something they have to do in order to
have that visibility in the search
results when people are looking for a
problem to be solved or for an answer to
their question as you learn search
engine optimization skills it will
greatly enhance your career you see once
you've developed these skills and you
develop some experience in this area
it's unlimited what you can do you can
become a specialist in search engine
optimization you can move into
management roles because you'll
understand many different channels and
how they relate to search and so you'll
be able to manage and operate in
different areas you can also move into
other channels because search is such a
foundation you can find new niche roles
such as copywriting programming research
or maybe even start your own company
many people who have SEO skills they've
been able to deepen them by working with
vendors within the search engine
industry or even with a search engine
themselves the good news is there's no
clear path you can find your skills you
can even create new opportunities now
when we talk about search engine
marketing that's more the broad-based
approach it's marketing through the use
of both paid and organic search I'll
explain those as we go along
now as we look at the page here this is
called the search engine results page
once you make a query you see a
combination of paid of organic and in
this case you'll see some shopping ads
as well this is the search engine
results page also known as the SERP
which is abbreviated SC R P that's an
acronym that you'll see constantly in
this industry now the search engine
results page based on what you search
can also have business listings Maps
events pictures video and other types of
information so it's important to know
what the search engine results page
typically will produce for your industry
and your type of business
now when we talk specifically about
search engine optimization that is the
practice of utilizing keywords in your
content in your page layout and in the
programming to increase visibility in
the search engine results what's
outlined here are the organic results on
the page as you can see there at the
bottom of the page they have less
visibility then paid placement and over
time you may notice that organic search
results receive less and less real
estate on the pages
now paid search marketing or what's
called pay-per-click or PPC which is the
abbreviation for pay-per-click this is
paid marketing or paid advertising in
the search results you see rather than
optimizing your website you can also bid
on the keyword term and when you bid on
it your ad can show up in the results
page the advertiser pays every time
somebody clicks on the ad
this is identified by either sponsored
or the word ad and you'll see those
either
up in the corner or next to the ad
itself now the individual pages that
make up the search results you'll see
that they all fit the same format
regardless of website they come from all
of the text is in the same format which
is controlled by the search engines when
we look at one specific result that is
called a snippet that's the information
about that webpage and that information
is taken from that web page however like
I said all the websites are shown the
same way search engines take the
information from the web page they
republish it in their own format and
that's the snippet it's a structured
presentation of the information from a
web page now the algorithm is something
you're going to hear a lot the algorithm
is a mathematical computation of
multiple factors to ascribe importance
or relevance to a large volume of
information you'll notice at the top of
the page there are 34 million results
out of 34 million results how can a
human determine what is going to be the
most important and what is not will an
algorithm if you'll see in that
highlighted area in less than 1/2 of a
second is able to filter through those
34 million webpages and produce what it
considers to be the highest quality most
relevant results to
or that term and the search engines are
in the business of making sure that that
is a high quality algorithm because the
customer is you the searcher if a search
engine does not provide good relevant
results to the searcher then they have
not done their job the ultimate goal is
to get people to come back and continue
to use the search engine so you the
searcher or the primary customer of the
search engines this is what the
algorithm is intended to do to provide
the best highest quality most relevant
result to the searcher out of millions
of web pages now I've said this word a
few times but key words the key word is
essentially what the user types into the
search bar to find information about
those words are important for us to know
as search engine optimizers we want to
understand what people are searching for
and the words they use so this is the
keyword or keyphrase that we're going to
be looking at throughout this course
next are a few measurement terms first
is impression impression is just simply
the number of times that your ad or your
result has been viewed now this just
means that the page has been produced as
results but there's been no interaction
other than the page being produced and
the listings being on the page that is
an impression the next way that we
measure is a click when someone clicks
on a result that is something we can
specifically measure that someone
searched on a term saw our website or
our webpage as a result and they clicked
on it and we can measure that
now the relevant terms here is something
that we can do for measurement and
looking at how relevant our page is and
what people do so we're looking at
clicks how many click throughs we
receive maybe for a certain term which
would provide us a click-through rate
when we compare the amount of clicks to
the amount of impressions
a visitor is someone who visits our
website now this doesn't just have to be
from search this can be from social
media it can be from someone typing in
our website directly or clicking a link
and coming to the site visitors are
people who visit your website
the term engagement really at its
clearest level is when a visitor
interacts with you and your website
meaning they do something that can be
measurable whether they click view a
page download a document interact with
your website somehow respond to
something or read anything that we can
measure we can call that engagement it's
the interactions that visitors have on
our web sites that we can measure and
know did they find what they were
looking for that's the ultimate
engagement that we're looking to measure
a referral is where the visitor came
from their source again that's just like
when we looked at visitors they can come
from anywhere search engines links ads
emails social media a referral is the
measurement of where they came from
this helps us determine which of our
marketing channels are more effective
than others and driving visitors to the
website a bounce is someone who clicks
on the result from the search engine
results and they come to our website
they view one page and leave that's a
bounce now from that we determine the
bounce rate and that is the amount of
people who have clicked on the result
and have left immediately sometimes that
can help us determine if there's a
problem with the page if too many people
are leaving when they decide that that
page is just not relevant to them
despite them searching on something very
similar this is important as we get into
the analytics in improving your website
and also improving your relevance for
specific terms now the business goals
and expectations of search engine
optimization typically revolve around
rankings and visibility most companies
when they retain the services of an SEO
company or individual the main way they
want to measure results is by rankings
one of the things we will cover is how
difficult it is to accurately measure
rankings regardless the primary goal
that businesses are trying to
accomplish beyond the rankings it's to
make money it's to establish business
goals and have conversions conversions
are the people that come to your site
and become new customers new contacts or
do something that meets a business goal
and then ultimately measuring a return
on investment that's looking at how well
our site is improving in visibility how
well it's improving and gaining
conversions and how well it's improving
monetarily in revenue and profitability
by the increased visibility of search
engine optimization now like I said most
companies are interested in gaining
those top rankings I've often told
people that is unreal expectations to be
number one consistently I always look
for consistency in the top rankings
because rankings are affected by a
number of factors they're affected by
the personalization you're browsing and
search history will affect the rankings
also where you live might affect the
rankings as well the number one thing I
look to do in search engine optimization
is I want to protect the terms that are
already ranking well and I want to
research keywords and also my user and
searcher intent in order to find the
right words for the rankings the
majority of time when I work with
companies I find that they simply are
not using the right words in order to
gain rankings ultimately rankings don't
matter if there are no sales and so
anytime I start a search engine
optimization engagement the number one
thing I want to know are the goals of
the business how do they make money you
see true SEO measurements are the
business results not just the rankings
someone has to make money to pay for the
SEO and so what kind of business is this
are you a publisher looking
purely for numbers of pageviews and
visitor counts are you looking for leads
through which to sell and groom those
leads to become sales or are you an
e-commerce site and you're trying to
sell things directly this is where you
need to state what kind of business you
are and state the ways that you make
money because this needs to be reflected
into how we will measure the
effectiveness and success of search
engine optimization so ask the question
what kind of business are you what
drives revenue and how can SEO improve
that revenue either through more
visitors or the specific type of
visitors by understanding better what
those visitors need and the problems
they have
you see SEO is going to go beyond
keywords into anticipating the problems
of future customers and being able to
reach them further and further before
the buying cycle maybe before they know
they even have the problem itself now
when a business talks about return on
investment what they want to know is
that if I spend $10,000 what will I get
in return
this is what every business wants to
know that if they spend this much in
marketing when will they see the results
now to set the expectations if they
spend that $10,000 in paid search in
pay-per-click marketing they're going to
see their return much faster primarily
because you can set your ad campaign to
run immediately as soon as you set the
budget and set up the campaign your
visibility will be at the top of the
search results on the first page but as
soon as your budget runs out your ads
will no longer show so the return on
investment from paid search is very fast
and it lasts as long as you have the
budget search engine optimization is
more of a long-term return on investment
depending upon the type of business you
have depending upon market forces or
trends within your industry sometimes
the return
an investment can be six months 12
months maybe even two years depending
upon numerous factors so it is always
good to understand the expectations of
really return on investment and all of
the factors involved in that return on
investment search engine optimization is
a long-term investment
well ranking websites typically will see
a faster result and so they will
experience it faster and newer websites
typically will see slower results
however once you gain those rankings you
typically will hold those rankings for
many years afterwards and will
continually experience a return on that
result this is always the question I get
from companies is how fast will I see
the results well and this is dependent
upon many factors number one it's
determined upon the age of the website
how long is this website been live in
its current form have there been other
changes or redesigns to this website
have they changed domain names and how
effective has their marketing been to
this point you see if it's a popular
website already and has some rankings
then applying search engine optimization
may help it faster and you may see a
return faster however if it's a brand
new website or a newer website that
maybe doesn't have the visibility of
exposure it's going to take more time it
may take additional marketing to see
better results and of course it depends
on market trends if you have a trend in
your market where the bulk of the
business takes place maybe one or two
months out of the year then depending
upon your time frame it may take 12 to
24 months to see results
however those rankings once you get them
tend to last and they tend not to change
much now depending upon your market and
how
fast new sites are developed or new
information is published that may change
some things
it also will depend upon your choice of
tactics and how strong your external
marketing is you see the marketing you
do online beyond your website and the
marketing you do offline will impact the
popularity of your website and also the
effectiveness of your measurement and
analytics will guide you in what to do
to take steps to improve your site and
improve your marketing beyond search
engine optimization so what are the
benefits professionally and from a
business focus search engine
optimisation provides the highest return
on investment of nearly any other
channel you can do for marketing it also
provides the most and the best lifetime
customers and the lowest cost per lead
or cost per sale than any other channel
will typically provide now the nice
thing about search engine optimization
is that it starts small there are many
tasks and details that you can quickly
learn such as keyword research once
you've got that mastered then you can
grow into other aspects it's a search
engine optimization enables you to start
small handle a few things and become
very good at that and then grow and you
can grow very quickly you can go into
very complex technical issues once
you've gotten the basics words are the
foundation and it provides a structure
for all your ongoing marketing
hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here